envie de célébrer les fêtes avec des ma
locaux sur votre table pour ce
calendrier de l'avent de tv78 je vous
fais découvrir la truite de la
pisculture de
[Musique]
Villette au cœur de la vallée de la veau
couleur dans le nord des Yvelines cette
pisculture est installée depuis 1896
truite arc-en-ciel farot ou jaune sont
élevés sur place dans des bassins le
nourrissage est manuel et garanti sans
OGM pour des saveurs exalté préférez les
fumer au feu de bois comptez 3 € pour
une truite fraîche de 250 g et 4,8 €
pour une truite fumée de 150 g alors
pour découvrir le goût authentique de ce
produit evelinois haut de gamme
rendez-vous dans la boutique sur
place